oh gosh i'm going to feel
really old making this video
hey everyone i'm abby sharp welcome to
abby's kitchen
[Music]
today's video is sponsored by built bar
and we'll be reviewing a harper's bazaar
food diaries for blink 182 drummer
travis barker oh man
how many embarrassingly angsty teenage
memories is this gonna hash up but first
let me tell you about my sponsor
buildbar i can't stop won't stop eating
these bars so you're just gonna have to
keep listening to me wax poetic about
them they're just so good but they're
probably one of the only protein bars
i've ever tried that actually tastes
really good and of course they're loaded
with protein so today's flavor
for my testing pleasure is
salted caramel today's a salted caramel
day mm-hmm
yeah
busting in
go go go go go belt bar go belt bar
you're salty you're sweet you're so good
to eat
so
this has 17 grams of protein
and they are lower sugar bars so if
you're using them as a post workout i
would suggest pairing them with some
fruit or oats or toast to get that
protein carb ratio in personally
i love them before bed that's like a
bedtime snack and i warm them up in the
microwave for like 10 seconds put a
little ice cream on top so so good
but if you want to give them a try check
out my link in the description and use
my promo code abby sharp15 to get 15 off
of your order
and of course you can pause the screen
or look at my description for a general
disclaimer including a trigger warning
as we will be of course discussing
macros and calories etc so feel free to
skip this video if it's not supportive
to your journey
also don't forget to subscribe to this
channel and ring that little bell so
that you never miss out on an episode so
my millennial friends likely know travis
barker from the 90s 2000s rock band
blink182
you know
they sang
all the small things which i still know
every word to
you guys
you guys know the song right
say it ain't so i will not go
turn the lights off
that was fun
anyways
what i didn't know was that this guy is
such a badass that he escaped a
terrifying plane crash in 2008 and as of
january he's also dating kourtney
kardashian so my gen zetters probably
know him by that but anyway the guy now
lives in la and in typical la fashion is
really into wellness culture he's also
vegan fyi so let's take a look at what
he eats in a day
i love coffee i love matcha also another
favorite thing to do is put a rice
tincture from barca wellness in those
drinks i like my coffee black
i'll either drink espressos or a vanilla
latte with oat milk as far as my matcha
i love it with oat or coconut milk i'll
add a little bit of maple syrup
sometimes a shot of espresso if i'm
really tired
this guy doesn't mess around with his
morning drink
and you guys know the drill you get your
coffee or tea however you like it this
girl won't say but in case you are
wondering what this whole tincture is
as the name might imply
travis's self-branded vegan line of
herbal infused thc free broad spectrum
cbd products now i'm not an expert on
cbd products as it's currently outside
the scope of registered dietitians to
advise on this though dietitians are
lobbying for this to change so who knows
maybe i'll become an expert soon but it
does look like barker's rise product is
a mixture of cbd
cgb which is another cannabinoid and
coffee arabica seed oil which is
described as a natural source of energy
now this sea oil is extracted by cold
pressing green coffee beans tealed a
mixture that is rich in antioxidants
like vitamin e all the research we have
on this has been done on topical
formulations for skin health and they
have found some promising results with
improvements in wrinkles firmness and
redness but how this translates to
drinking it in your coffee
is admittedly completely
unclear
i don't know what that was but anyways
like you said you do your coffee routine
your way and it makes sense that this
guy wants to of course plug his new
brand let's take a look at breakfast if
i'm going to eat breakfast my favorite
breakfast in the world is chicken and
waffles from crossroads it's vegan it's
delicious
that does look delicious
chicken and waffles is one of my
all-time favorite brunch meals so i am
intrigued by the vegan take now
obviously not every meal needs to be
super well balanced and let's be real a
breakfast made up of waffles and any
kind of fried food
isn't designed to be the most nutrient
dense option even if it is vegan and
that is 100
okay
i actually kind of appreciate it when i
see ethical vegans choose fun foods
because i think it's an important
reminder for folks with dietary
restrictions that plant-based foods can
also be emotionally satisfying and
shouldn't necessarily trigger scarcity
mentality my favorite meal to cook would
be the impossible sausage patties mix
that with the folly heart egg an english
muffin maybe some food on the side okay
so this on the other hand takes both
boxes for me pretty well which is an
inherently balanced meal that also feels
really fun and delish so we've got
protein and fat in the vegan sausages
and egg plus carbs and fiber in the
english muffin and fruit now i get asked
a lot about whether or not i think these
faux vegan products are actually healthy
and my answer is
well
honestly it depends how you define
healthy but let's talk about the
impossible foods sausage first if you
look at all of the ingredients it's
largely made up of water soy protein
sunflower oil and coconut oil with some
small amounts of some stabilizers and
flavors in there if we were to compare
this patty to a similar sized mcdonald's
sausage patty
you'd be looking at almost half the
calories in the vegan version with
significantly less saturated fat and a
comparable amount of sodium and protein
but calories aren't everything and i do
know that a lot of people may worry
about the ingredients in these faux meat
products namely the addition of
sunflower oil now how concerning
sunflower oil is really comes down to
how much of it you consume your overall
diet and also what type of sunflower oil
we're even talking about
some varieties are higher in
monounsaturated fats while others which
are more common tend to be higher in
omega-6 polyunsaturated fats and it's
known that polyunsaturated fats consumed
in excess
may have some pro-inflammatory effects
in the body but the bigger concern is
not just omega-6s in isolation but
rather the omega-3 to six ratio of your
overall diet so it's ideal to consume
enough omega-3s in your diet to balance
out your intake of those omega-6s and my
take on this is that if you're consuming
a varied diet and enjoying these
processed foods in moderation along with
more unprocessed plant-based options
like beans legumes nuts and seeds
particularly those that are rich in
omega-3 fats like walnuts flax hemp and
chia it's not really something we need
to worry about as for the egg the faux
egg contains more than twice the
calories for comparable volume with the
real egg
but it also has twice the protein and it
also has no saturated fat the faux egg
does contain some gums or stabilizers
like cellulose or carrageenan which i
think are fine in moderation but these
can be triggering for some folks with
digestive issues so again
which one of these foods are healthier
really depends on your unique goals and
triggers
and ultimately i'm just really glad that
we have options like this for folks with
dietary restrictions who still want to
enjoy a wide variety of food experiences
and meals the airwang i love their
meatless beef and broccoli i usually
have that with like a side of green
beans or broccoli or rice or brussels
sprouts
that cracks that's one of my favorite
and then i love their tumeric smoothie
okay is it just me or does every
la-based celebrity featured on food
diaries mention air one like at least
once so this is definitely a place i
gotta hit up also this meatless beef
stir fry looks like an awesome option
we're getting lots of green veggies and
some protein and fat in the faux beef
plus some carbs if he opts for the side
of rice i will just mention that i'm
going to assume all three of the meals
that he's mentioned so far utilize
processed soy based protein which again
totally fine in moderation but i do like
to see more variety whenever we can
so sneaking in some beans lentils nuts
seeds hemp quinoa etc will help ensure
he's getting a nice variety of amino
acids as well as some less processed
options as well also i feel like
turmeric lattes were really 2019
so i don't know our tumeric smoothies
the upgraded 2021 version please
jenzetter's
give me the facts here update me so
travis's version contains beet juice
carrot juice orange juice turmeric
obviously plus camu camu which is a sour
berry rich in vitamin c now i don't know
about specific quantities in this
smoothie but what we do know is that
only 50 grams of camu camu berries
provides 16 times your daily requirement
for vitamin c and even without the
addition of the camu camu we're already
getting plenty of vitamin c from the
orange and carrot and beet juice in the
smoothie plus the broccoli or brussels
sprouts or veggies from his meal in fact
just a single cup of orange juice alone
provides twice your needs of vitamin c
for the day i mean it's always great to
focus on getting enough vitamin c if
you're vegetarian or vegan specifically
to help improve the absorption of that
non-heme iron but in travis case the
camu camu is probably just a little
bougie overkill but hey if he likes the
taste or if he just likes saying the
name like i do like camu camu it sounds
like a cute little pet name
and also i honestly just assume he can
afford the luxurious upgrade
then hey
i say
why not that's the la way i guess i try
my best to avoid gluten it doesn't make
me feel the best i mean
tell me you're dating a kardashian
without telling me you're dating a
kardashian no but seriously whether or
not travis avoids gluten because he's
dating the gluten-free queen herself if
it doesn't make him feel good then it's
definitely best to limit or avoid it and
being based in la i imagine gluten-free
products are very easy to come by since
it feels like i know every californian
and their grandma has sworn off gluten
even when they don't know
what gluten is
but what but what is gluten
this is pretty sad because i don't know
but here's a little secret from your not
so trendy dietitian from the north
unless you have celiac or diagnosed
non-celiac gluten intolerance a
gluten-free diet
is probably actually
less healthy for you a lot of
gluten-free foods are lower in fiber
higher in additives sugar and
stabilizers and are ultimately more
refined and since travis is also vegan
if he's going to also eliminate a lot of
beneficial grains i would just want to
be on the lookout to ensure he's meeting
his needs for things like vitamin b12
and iron so when looking for gluten-free
alternatives choose one that is
fortified whenever possible
also choose one that's higher in fiber
and lower in sugar and aim to fill those
nutrient gaps with other whole food
sources of these nutrients like tofu soy
milk nuts seeds legumes and dark leafy
greens yes i love snacks throughout the
day probably my favorite bar
is a bar called get mine right there
peanut butter bar is amazing i also like
almonds nuts pistachios bananas with
almond butter or
sometimes an avocado smoothie with dates
and plant-based protein lots of great
snack ideas here all of which are like
loaded with my hunger crushing
combination
so we've got carbs fiber protein and fat
in the banana nut butter combo also nuts
straight up are always a satisfying
snack because they also pack all three
but if you want to like up the
satisfaction factor there he could throw
in a little carbs with some fresh or
dried fruit now i feel like the avocado
smoothie is definitely courtney inspired
since she is the avocado smoothie queen
but it also just really does sound like
a balanced snack with the fat and the
fiber from the avocado
carbs in the dates and protein in the
protein powder now i also looked up the
get mind right peanut butter bar which
he mentioned which seems to follow theme
with travis's appreciation for
functional nutrition nutrition wise i
love that the bar has an impressive 11
grams of protein and 7 grams of fiber
with only 4 grams of added sugar plus
it's got lots of healthy fats in there
since peanuts are the first ingredient
on the ingredient list but what makes
this bar unique is it's happy brain
blend which combines mct oil adaptogens
and nootropics like ashwagandha
mushrooms and ginseng now admittedly the
research in this area is pretty spotty
as to whether or not these herbs and
oils do what they say they do so for
example there is some promising research
that ashwagandha may help to reduce
stress which we'll discuss later on but
there is also a lack of convincing
evidence that ginseng has any mood
enhancing effects as for the mct oil
research suggests that it may improve
brain function particularly in
individuals with epilepsy alzheimer's
and autism however it's unclear if these
benefits are from a combination of mct
oil and following a ketogenic diet or if
they come from the use of mct oil alone
as for the mushrooms
[Music]
there is some research to show that they
may help to boost energy levels and
exercise performance however research on
humans is quite limited and there's
currently no consensus on a safe or
effective dosage the main concern with
this bar is that we don't actually know
how much of these functional ingredients
you're getting so like a mushroom could
cough on the bar and we could
theoretically add the fancy ingredient
to the ingredient list but again the
nutrition here does look good in the bar
and hey if they taste as good as they
sound i mean i am down for anything
peanut butter related then
they are a okay by me after a workout i
like to make a protein shake it usually
has plant-based protein powder a banana
some type of milk either almond coconut
milk flaxseed oil flax seed
cinnamon
dates that's pretty much like my go-to
and then i'll put the recovery tincture
from bark around the center as well all
right so as a post workout smoothie this
does look pretty good for a recreational
gym warrior so we've got protein in the
protein powder for muscle protein
synthesis fast acting carbs in the
banana and dates to help replenish the
glycogen
plus some healthy fats and fiber in the
flax now depending on how much flax oil
is in there i would say that hardcore
fitness enthusiasts might say that the
flax oil plus the flax seeds might be
overkill for post-workout i mean some
folks find that too much fat after
workout slows down their recovery but
i'm also just gonna assume that he's not
like dumping it in so it's probably okay
now travis also of course has to plug
his tincture again
this one like his morning blend also
contains cbd and cgb however this blend
is unique in that it also contains
ashwagandha extract for alleged stress
reduction along with red reishi mushroom
extract for immune support now as i
alluded to a moment ago there is some
promising research showing that
ashwagandha may help to reduce stress
and anxiety so one study found that 69
of study participants with chronic
stress reported a reduction in anxiety
and insomnia when supplementing with
ashwagandha similarly another study
found that 88 of participants reported a
reduction in stress now as for the
reishi mushrooms the research is
admittedly mixed as to whether or not it
really has any impact on immune health
and it's also unclear if the mushrooms
are more effective in those already sick
versus in healthy individuals i also
want to quickly point out that this
tincture also contains mct oil and hemp
seed oil which also adds an additional
source of fat to the protein shake which
as i said earlier may not be so
advantageous for a post workout snack my
favorite food city is los angeles we are
spoiled with so many great options for
food and i wouldn't trade for anything
okay so i do agree la is a great food
city but
is it the best food city no
definitely not i mean
oh
sorry la friends it's just not argue
with me right in the comments i know i'm
right about this
maybe it's great if you have like a
bunch of food restrictions because
i know i'm sure there's no shortage of
overpriced vegan keto gluten-free juice
bars that you can frequent in la but of
all the cities that i've traveled to eat
i would say ellie is probably one of the
least inspired and most overpriced in
fyi i'm not trolling la i'm so not
auntie la i actually
love la i got married in malibu and all
of california has a really important
special place in my heart and i would
live there in a heartbeat if it was
easier to move across borders but for
the record san fran is a much better
food city in california as are like a
dozen other american cities if we are
just talking the us i think when you go
outside the la bubble you can see that
plain and clear my typical dinner is
matsuhisa or nobu
vegan sushi i also really love
all the gluten-free vegan pasta options
at crossroads kitchen i'm more than
likely ordering the bolognese
or the pizza also calamari caesar salad
or artichoke oysters
okay so i know i just trolled la hard
but
i really do appreciate creativity in the
kitchen and when a chef is finding fun
ways to make vegan calamari and oysters
look and taste like real seafood
[Music]
[Applause]
i gotta give them major props i also
appreciate that despite having dietary
restrictions which seem potentially both
possibly health and ethics related
travis still finds ways to enjoy the
food that he craves this is generally a
really good sign that your intentions
are in the right place and that your
diet restrictions are not forcing you
into scarcity mentality we love to see
it even if it means the guy has to name
drop all the celebrity hot spots in l.a
i think that's just the l.a wig i
actually love desserts one of my
favorite desserts is the sundae from
crossroads kitchen
another one of my favorites is the
shaved ice from montsehisa i also
love love love the coconut sorbet from
no blue and mozzies
oh man yes to all of the above
i mean dinner for me is just not quite
complete at a restaurant without
ice cream for dessert and i'm loving all
of these vegan options but also
are these actually the only three
restaurants the guy goes to i mean for
living in such a metropolitan city with
such vast food offerings
you'd think he would venture outside of
his like celebrity infested nobu dining
bubble and i don't know grab an
authentic taco or something oh travis
i know i'm trolling him hard but this
interview is just so la i can't help
myself the last thing i usually put in
my body before i go to sleep is the
barker wellness sleep tincture
it allows me to have a full night's rest
i wake up feeling refreshed it's a game
changer
another tincture
anyways travis finishes the night with
another cbd product and this one for
sleep fittingly also contains melatonin
and valerian root extract so super
quickly
melatonin is the sleep hormone that our
bodies naturally produce to control our
sleep wake cycle and while we do produce
it naturally like i said
research suggests that supplementing
does have some benefits for folks
struggling with
sleep hey
okay so for example one small study
showed that when supplementing with
melatonin two hours before bed
individuals with insomnia were able to
fall asleep faster and enjoy a better
quality sleep similarly a large
meta-analysis looking at individuals
with sleep disorders also demonstrated
positive effects of melatonin
supplementation
so if you watch my bedtime routine video
you know that i'm a fan of it myself
however it's important to note that it
can interact with some medications like
antidepressants and blood pressure
medication and is not recommended for
certain populations like pregnant women
or kids so of course always speak to
your doctor before starting a supplement
like this as for the valerian root
research has likewise shown that it may
help to reduce the amount of time it
takes to fall asleep while also
improving sleep quality
one study even found that participants
were able to achieve deep sleep 36
faster
however it's important to note that cbd
products in general are not well
regulated in the united states as they
are not fda approved so even though they
are technically legal at the federal
level cbd drive products may still be
illegal under some state laws and
non-prescription cbd products may be
inaccurately labeled in terms of their
quality quantity and alleged benefits
canada on the other hand does regulate
cbd under the cannabis act and implants
a strict regulatory system over its
production and distribution
making it more accessible and safe for
the general public i also wasn't able to
find any information on the barker
website about third-party testing so
i'm not saying that these products are
dangerous but i mean i'm not saying
they're not so what are my overall
thoughts on travis barker's diet well
i would say we've had a good fair game
of wellness culture bs bingo haven't we
i mean it's always a bit of a home run
with la-based celebs but throw in a
kardashian love affair and you are bound
to get some grade a woo here we've got
tinctures superfoods nootropics
adaptogens smoothies and a lot of
celebrity restaurant name dropping but
really what do we expect from an x
rocker turned kardashian bow what i do
really appreciate is that despite his
dietary restrictions his intention with
his diet seems to be in a good place
he's still allowing himself a wide range
of higher fat higher carb comfort foods
so his diet is not lacking in the fun
factor or calories and i'm not hearing a
lot of moralizing language around food
now from a nutrition perspective i think
that travis seems to be getting enough
fiber fat carbs and protein my only
suggestion would be to try to switch up
the source of protein whenever he can so
rather than relying on ultra processed
soy meats and powders all the time i
would encourage trying to work in more
whole food sources of protein like beans
lentils hemp nuts and sieves
and on that note that is all that i have
for you guys today thank you again to
buildbar for sponsoring this video if
you liked it be sure to give it the
thumbs up leave me a comment below on
who you'd like to see me review next
subscribe to the channel and i'll see
you next time on abby's kitchen
bye
and for more great videos like this
check out the link right here
you